over the past few months we've been
seeing rumors of Apple working on a
gaming console which could apparently
compete with the PlayStation 5 and the
Xbox series acts now a lot of you guys
are gonna laugh at that because gaming
isn't really Apple strong soon but I've
been digging through Apple's developer
videos and I'm seeing Apple do things
that they've never done before in terms
of gaming and then if you add in certain
rumors and leaks that have been going
around I'm convinced that Apple is gonna
make a huge push into gaming very soon
so in this video I'm gonna discuss the
current problem with gaming on Apple
devices I'm gonna talk about this
rumored console and what I think it's
going to end up being I'm gonna tell you
why it finally makes sense for Apple
device gaming to make a huge comeback
and I'm gonna reveal everything that I
found in Apple's developer videos that
led me to believe that all of this is
going to happen by far the biggest
problem with gaming and Apple devices is
that it just hasn't been worth the
effort for a lot of game developers of
course the gaming market for iPhone and
iPad is huge and it's been growing over
the years but that's just not the case
for the Mac and for the Apple TV in
order for a game developer to bring
their game to the Mac or the Apple TV
they had to build their games using the
metal framework and to do that their
entire team had to be using Mac
computers so that's a big investment for
a company that uses Windows machines for
their game development and if they did
end up making that investment they would
run into an issue where the gaming
market wasn't big enough to make it
worth it in this article from Fast
Company raffia games created an Apple TV
version of their game kingdom new lands
and five months after launch they only
sold about 600 units on Apple TV
compared to 54,000 for the iOS version
minecraft Apple TV edition was released
in 2016 but it was actually discontinued
in 2018 so they could reallocate
resources to the platforms that their
players use the most only a couple of
months ago valve ended steamvr support
for Mac OS so they could focus on
Windows and Linux and back in January of
this year the developers of rocket
League and it's the
for Mac OS and Linux platforms because
it was no longer viable to maintain the
game on those platforms so what we're
seeing is a trend of developers ditching
the Mac in the Apple TV and the main
reason is that they have to spend a lot
of extra time and resources updating and
fixing bugs specifically for those
platforms but that's not the only reason
why developers are avoiding them for
example on the Apple TV the Siri remote
is incredibly limiting and it simply
doesn't work for a lot of games yes
other game controllers are supported but
according to Gordon van Dijk from Roth
Fury games not a lot of people buy
additional controllers for their Apple
TV so what kills their ability to bring
their games to that platform so what can
Apple do to fix this well a developer
named Patrick Hogan told Ars Technica
that Apple needs to do three things to
fix gaming on the Apple TV 1 they need
to include a full-featured gaming
controller with every Apple TV 2
they have to market the Apple TV as a
gaming platform and 3 they have to spend
money on funding exclusive games for
that platform and as far as the Mac
Apple needs to figure out a way to
finally make it worth it for developers
to bring their games to the Mac and
based on everything I've seen in the
Apple developer videos it's obvious that
Apple is making major moves toward
fixing these issues releasing a new
gaming console and making a massive push
into the gaming market it all started
last year with a few very important
changes the first was that Apple finally
brought ps4 and Xbox one controller
support to all of their Apple devices
and the iPad pro finally started getting
some great games that supported
controllers like Fortnight and Call of
Duty mobile and at the same time Apple
released the Apple arcade which works
across all of their platforms and of
course supports game controllers but
this year is where Apple is going
all-out for starters they're bringing
keyboard and mouse gaming to the iPad
for game categories like first-person
shooters and MOBA
this is gonna play into gaming on Mac
which I'll get into in just a minute
gaming and Apple devices is limited to
using the metal framework and for the
first time ever
Apple has opened up their metal
developer tools to be used in Windows 10
so essentially game developer Studios
that use pcs for their entire team can
now finally build games for Apple
devices without having to invest into a
full set of Mac computers Apple is also
going big on controller support this
year adding support for new controllers
like the Xbox elite Wireless series 2
and they're adding a ton of new sensor
support like haptic feedback Rumble new
motion sensor support including the
gyroscope ps4 controller light bar
support battery level support a new API
which automatically switches between
controllers on the Apple TV in the most
important thing of all a game controller
input remapping support
so basically Apple is setting up
full-fledged controller support for the
first time ever now yes all of that new
support sounds great but how is Apple
gonna convince developers to finally
start making games for all of their
platforms well it all comes down to
their new Apple silicon as I'm sure all
of you know by now apples Mac's are
going to transition away from Intel
processors to use their own custom built
arms 64 chips instead the most important
benefit in terms of gaming is this
second if you have any shared code with
iOS apps that code is almost certainly
already fully ported to arm 64 because
iOS uses the same CPU architecture as
apple silicon mac computers so basically
on day one Apple silicon Macs are gonna
be able to natively run iPhone and iPad
apps and if you don't believe me listen
to this Big Sur on Apple silicon allows
you to run iOS apps natively on the Mac
without recompilation and if you're
wondering how a touch based app will
work on a Mac Apple will take care of it
automatically iOS is built around a
recked multi-touch interaction model but
mac OS is built around an indirect
cursor based interaction model the
infrastructure automatically Maps mini
multi-touch gestures so the point that
I'm trying to make is that every iPhone
or iPad game should be able to run on
Apple silicon Macs with very minimal
changes and if a game supports a mouse
and keyboard on the iPad it'll
automatically gain the same support on
the Mac and if you're wondering about
how a game built for an iPhone or an
iPad UI will run on a Mac Apple has that
covered as well last year Apple
introduced Swift UI which allows you to
create user interfaces across all of
Apple's devices all at once so now
instead of learning different UI code
for each platform Apple has consolidated
it all into one which is Swift UI so you
can build one app for one platform and
it's now many many times easier to bring
it to the rest of apple's platforms
since it shares a lot of the same code
and on top of that in March a Polly
added Universal purchase for Mac apps so
when you buy an app or pay for an in-app
purchase it works across all Apple
platforms by purchasing it just once and
this year Apple has finally redesigned
the game center with new features like
tracking achievements leaderboards and
profiles and it works across all of
Apple's platforms they've also made
updates to replay kit for the Mac which
allows you to have in-app screen
recording screen capture and even live
streaming of your gameplay and it even
works with buttons on game controllers
so what um ultimately leading to you is
that for the first time ever every Apple
device runs on Apple silicon this is
huge because a game developer can create
a game just one time and use Swift UI to
make minimal changes to the code so that
the game looks great on every Apple
device including the iPhone the iPad the
Mac and the Apple TV and when you buy or
download a game you get to play it on
any Apple device including your in-app
purchases and the updated Universal Game
Center
means that your in-game progress can be
saved across all of the platforms and
since each of them now has full-fledged
controller support you can use one
controller to play on all of them and
now that all of the platform's run on
Apple silicon online multiplayer cross
play between these platforms is possible
on third-party games just like it
already is with Apple arcade what this
basically means is that the gaming
market for each Apple platform is going
to be merged into one massive gaming
market this is going to have huge
benefits for gaming on the Mac since
it'll instantly have access to a massive
library of iOS and iPad OS games but the
most important change of all is that
game developers will no longer have to
create update and fix bugs for multiple
platforms they simply have to do it once
and make minimal code adjustments for
each platform making it take much less
time than ever before now a lot of you
guys are going to say that mobile gaming
isn't real gaming but what you need to
understand is that this transition is
just the beginning because the different
Apple platforms will be merging in terms
of game development there is going to be
more incentive than ever before for game
developers to create new demanding
titles for Apple devices and because
Apple ships are becoming increasingly
more powerful with each year and apples
metal 2 is now adding high-end features
like ray-tracing developers can now
create really great triple-a title games
for Apple devices so basically all of
these new features that Apple has been
adding over the past year and especially
at this year's WWDC are signaling a
massive move from Apple to re-enter the
gaming market so with all of that said
let me show you guys how I think Apple
is gonna handle this big push into
gaming sometime later this year they're
gonna announce a new Apple TV with a
very powerful apple silicon chip that is
going to have a dedicated cooling
solution and they're gonna market it as
a gaming device there's also a good
chance that they're gonna release the
rumored Apple branded gaming controller
could be included with or bundled with
the new Apple TV and it's also going to
support every Apple device like the
iPhone and the Mac and at the same time
they'll show off how switching to Apple
silicon has allowed them to enable cross
play multiplayer which allows you to
play the same game on any Apple device
whether you're at home or on the go
they'll also talk about how it's easier
than ever before for developers to
create update and fix bugs for each of
their platforms all at the same time
instead of having to dedicate lots of
time and resources to support all of the
different Apple platforms they could
even work with a major triple-a game
developer to bring a massive popular
title to Apple devices to help market
their new push for gaming and with time
as gaming on the Mac and the Apple TV
continues to grow alongside iOS gaming
more and more developers will start to
bring their games over to Apple
platforms and thanks to the advancements
and processor performance and Apple
silicon technology Apple devices will be
able to run more powerful games than
ever before so there you guys have it
that's how I think Apple is gonna make a
huge push into the gaming market
starting later this year if you disagree
with me go ahead and let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below and if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and tap the like button and click
the circle above to subscribe and make
sure to check out some of our other
Apple silicon content right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]